pour alex docherty la pomme de terre
c'est une histoire de famille depuis six
générations 83 ans son père inspectent
encore chacune des pommes de terre ici
la politique comme les patates c'est une
tradition on vote libéral ou
progressistes conservateurs depuis plus
de 120 ans des gouvernements
majoritaires libéraux ou progressistes
conservateurs gouvernent en continu dans
toute l'histoire de la province
seuls trois députés de tierces parties
ont siégé à l'assemblée législative
alex constate l'engouement pour le parti
vert mais il n'a aucune envie de céder à
cette mode
chose certaine c'est la première fois de
l'histoire de la province qu'en début de
campagne
un parti autre que le parti libéral et
le parti progressiste conservateur mais
dans les sondages un parti plus modéré
qu avant avec 50 nuances de vert
mais pour alex ce n'est qu'une façade il
craint que si les verts prennent le
pouvoir
il impose des mesures draconiennes comme
augmenter la taxe sur le carbone et
bannir les pesticides
[Musique]
la province est la plus grande
productrice de pommes de terre au pays
l'industrie emploie 12 % des prince
édouardien et génère plus d'un milliard
de dollars en retombées économiques
selon alex le parti vert n'a pas l'appui
les agriculteurs devant une salle comble
lors d'un débat des chefs sur
l'environnement
le ton est différent
[Applaudissements]
ce politologue crois que l'hiver utilise
une forme de populisme pour renforcer
leur appui tous les scénarios sont donc
possibles le soir de l'élection le soir
que le jeu mais chose certaine le vent
de changement ne s'est pas rendue
jusqu'à cette ferme
ici elisa céret radio canada à l'île du
prince édouard